das ist ein spektakulärer fund einem
bachelor studenten aus kanada hat ihn
gerade gemacht bei der analyse von nasa
daten hat sie 17 exoplaneten entdeckt
darunter ist auch eine unglaubliche
entdeckung eine potenzielle zweite erde
und dieser planet ja man kann nicht
sagen er ist möglicherweise bewohnbar
aber es könnte dort leben geben und das
versetzt die forschungswelt den aufbau
klicks und science fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen die junge
astronomie studenten michelle con moto
von der university of british columbia
in kanada wurde durch star trek
inspiriert sich der astronomie zu widmen
schon in der highschool war sie
begeistert davon wie wissenschaftler
dort als abenteurer gezeigt wurden und
wie optimistisch die scifi serie auf die
zukunft der menschheit blickt im herbst
will sie ihren master in arts for me
beginnen und pünktlich zu ihrem
abschluss hat sie jetzt eine
unglaubliche entdeckung gemacht 17
bisher unbekannte exoplaneten also
planeten die jenseits unseres
sonnensystems liegen die planeten hat
sie mit hilfe von daten der kepler
mission der nasa aufgespürt das
weltraumteleskop kepler suchte bis
herbst 2008 10 den sternenhimmel nach
planeten ab und forschen dabei vor allem
nach bewohnbaren extrasolaren planeten
auf denen flüssiges wasser existieren
könnte immer wenn ein planet vor einem
stern vorbeizieht blockiert er einen
teil des lichts und die helligkeit des
sterns nimmt vorübergehend ab es sind
transit an dem stern vorbei wenn man so
einen transit festgestellt hat kann man
informationen wie die größe eines
planeten oder die dauer seiner
umlaufbahn ermitteln
juni motor hat dabei vor allem nach sehr
schwachen transit 'nen ausschau gehalten
also nach kleinen nur schwer zu
erkennenden einbrüchen
sie gingen davon aus dass das kepler
team diese übersehen haben könnte oder
sogar als fehlalarme abgetan und sie
nicht weiter untersucht haben könnte
einem wirklich ziemlich geniale idee und
das ganze war von erfolg gekrönt denn
sie machte mit 17 planeten eine
erstaunliche entdeckung damit nicht
genug unter den exoplaneten gibt es noch
einen ganz besonderen fund eine zweite
erde sie hat eine ähnliche größe wie
unser heimatplanet und befindet sich
auch in der habitablen zone ihres sterns
wäre also potenziell bewohnbar sie liegt
etwa 1000 lichter
von uns entfernt und heißt offiziell kec
7340 28 8 b ein jahr dieses erdähnlichen
planeten dauert 142 1 halbtage und er
umkreist seinen stern mit 0,44
astronomischen einheiten eine
astronomische einheit ist ja der
mittlere abstand zwischen der erde und
unserer sonne
das macht seine umlaufbahn etwas größer
als die des merkur in unserem
sonnensystem erhält etwa ein drittel des
lichts dass die erde erreicht solche
potenziell bewohnbaren planeten sind
unsere größte chance um außerirdisches
leben im weltraum zu finden vermutlich
eher der aber eher den riesenplaneten in
unserem eigenen sonnensystem da seine
oberfläche wahrscheinlich gasförmig und
nicht felsig wie unsere erde ist damit
ist ja eigentlich nicht der beste
kandidat als heimat für lebewesen
allerdings könnte sein mond groß genug
sein um das vorkommen von flüssigem
wasser und damit leben zu unterstützen
die studentin vergleicht das mit dem
planeten pandora aus dem film avatar der
eigentlich kein planet war sondern ein
bewohnbarer mond der einen riesigen
planeten umkreist auf dem es
extraterrestrisches leben gab der
erdähnliche planet hat von allen keppler
planeten einen der längsten um
laufzeiten und das macht ihn zu einem
extrem seltenen fund korrekter weise
müssen wir übrigens noch von einem
planeten kandidaten sprechen bisher
durch eine unabhängige untersuchung als
planet bestätigt wird ihre entdeckung
sorgt in der fachwelt für großes
aufsehen denn sie zeigt dass in den
kepler daten tatsächlich noch
zusätzliche und wissenschaftlich sehr
interessante planeten kandidaten zu
finden sind die noch nicht entdeckt
wurden
und das hat aufregende auswirkungen auf
die suche nach leben in der galaxie kuli
motor möchte neben ihrem master studium
gerne weiter daran forschen
denn bisher hat sie erst 400 keppler
licht kurven untersucht und es gibt noch
tausende andere die erforscht werden
können alle bisher entdeckten
exoplaneten auf einem bild anklicken
anschauen und egis kosmos abonnieren
neuer kanal bei unserem wissenschafts
netzwerk es 1054 bis dann bleibt dran